-Our first guest tonight
is the talented actor and
writer, you know,
from such shows is "It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia"
and films like
"Horrible Bosses,"
he stars in "I Want You Back,"
which premieres on
Amazon Prime Video February
11th. Let's take a look.
-People like to be my friend.
I'm extremely affable.
You know, in college,
all the girls were like,
"You're such a good friend."
-Oh, darn it.
-But, but but the point is,
people like to be my friend.
-Right.
-I get in his head.
-That's exactly right.
You get in his head
and then you make him realize
that Jenny isn't that great.
-She's not that great.
-Yeah. And that I am the one
that got away.
-Hey, do you really think
we could do this?
-Yes, I do.
-I'm in if you're in.
-I will seduce Logan.
You will friendship, seduce Noah
and we will win back our people.
-Alright.
-Please welcome to the show,
Charlie Day, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome! It is lovely
to have you here.
-It's good to be back
with people.
Right? Isn't it nice to be
in a room with people?
-Yeah, at a distance.
-At a distance.
Yeah, it's nice that this gap is
just perfect.
You realize this is
why castles had moats.
You know.
-It was COVID protocol.
-Yeah, you know, very early.
It was plague protocol.
They were going to be, yes, if
they had the plague.
You had to be very determined
to get in the castle.
-Yeah, exactly.
-He's coughing a lot,
but he's he's getting
across that moat.
Yeah, well, anyways.
-You --
We met in this building in 2011
when you hosted "SNL,"
which was fantastic.
It was a fantastic week for us.
We were huge fans of yours.
Did you enjoy that time?
-Yeah, that was like
the greatest time in my life.
It's been a while.
What's going on?
-Yeah.
-You know, I think it's time
to have me back.
-Right? Yeah.
I mean, you've been very busy.
-I've been busy.
-It was an excellent episode.
Have you gone back
and watched it?
-You know what?
I've never watched it.
-Okay.
-I've never watched it.
And not because I don't like
watching myself, which I don't.
But no, because it was such
a good time and it's such an it
like it was always a dream
for me to be on the show
and I didn't want
my viewing of it
to replace my memory
of the experience.
-Yeah.
-So, no, I've never seen it.
I hear it's good.
-It's really good.
You did a really good job.
-Thank you.
You are the head writer still at
the time.
-I was the head writer
at the time. Yeah.
-And then did they fire you?
Right after that episode.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Oh, I'm so sorry.
-I was like.
-I'm so sorry.
-I kept trying to pin it on you.
And they said,
"No, it was your
responsibility."
-You think you think
that guy's funny? All right.
You, but you do.
You're an executive producer
on "Sunny."
So you do have to. Let's give it
up for "Sunny" about it.
I mean, mind blowing.
-Oh, 15 years.
-15 years.
-Yeah.
-It is there's not
a lot of shows -- there are
No shows, no comedies.
-Season 1 I was six years old.
-That's amazing.
Because that's the thing you
were I mean,
because you were playing 10.
-Yeah, I look,
I looked bad for six. Yeah.
-Everybody did say that.
Yeah, there's a six year
old looks rough.
-He's heavy.
Does he smoke? Yeah.
So you -- but you do have
to watch yourself in episodes.
How has that been
not just watching yourself,
but watching yourself
over 15 seasons?
-I developed like a weird sort
of almost like, you know,
Rickey Henderson used
to talk about himself,
or he'd be like,
"Rickey stole a lot of bases."
-Yeah.
-So I'm like that
where I'm like, I don't think
Charlie would do that.
Let's let's get Charlie
going over there.
It's a different human
being to me.
Yeah, I need to disassociate
from that.
-That's probably healthy.
Considering everything
that happens on that show.
-Yeah, considering he huffs glue
and eats cat food.
I think it's good for me to...
-I love -- I talked about this
with you this summer
because we we have not seen
each other since 2011.
Then we ran into each other
on the beach this summer.
-And now somebody told me
that you're not a beach person.
-I hate the beach.
-Then you looked like
Bobby Kennedy meets Tom Hanks
in "Cast Away."
You look like
the most beachy man
I've ever seen in my life. Like,
you had, like ripped shorts.
And you came out of the ocean
with driftwood and you said,
I just made that I made a fire
and pizza
and like little 10 kids
running around.
-Yeah.
Well, my wife loves the beach.
So I'm like making
the most of it, but.
-The beach likes you.
-Yeah.
Well, that's the that's
the heartbreaking thing, right?
It would be like if LeBron James
hated basketball, like...
-Yeah, yeah.
-I'm built for it.
-You're made for the beach.
-And yet I hate every second.
-The beach hates me.
-The beach hates you.
-The beach is trying to scorch
me and drown me.
-Yeah you. Yeah, the whole time
you were, like, hunched over.
-Yeah, yeah, that's right.
I dug a hole and bury myself
up, like, it's fine.
Let me know when
the time gets up.
-Yeah, that's right.
We had to keep moving you back.
-That's yeah, that's true.
-You wait.
But we were talking about it,
and I talked with Glen about it.
Like how hard it is to come up
with new premises
after everything you have
put your characters on "Sunny"
through over 15 seasons.
-Yeah, yeah, it's hard work.
[ Both laugh ]
Yeah, you know, we lock
ourselves in a room that well,
the good news is that we do do
a lot of sort of political humor
not like on the nose,
but just like, you know,
if there's a pandemic,
we're probably going to do
an episode about it.
-Of course.
-And the world keeps having
crazy [bleep] happen, man.
-That's true.
Yeah.
-Yeah. When you think
about the beginning, yeah,
you're right.
It's like 15 years of things
that have been in the ether
that we've been talking about.
-Yeah, it seems to be nonstop,
you know?
So I'm just like,
I have like episodes prepped for
when the aliens come and like,
Yeah, I know I knew
this was going to happen.
I got a whole bit here.
-Ready to go.
-Yeah.
-So this is really a great movie
with Jenny Slate,
who's absolutely wonderful.
-Yes.
-It's a romcom of sorts.
-That's a romcom. Absolutely.
-Great.
[ Laughter ]
I guess it's true.
I was gonna say
It was based on what you guys do
and you
try to break up a relationship.
So I think maybe that's like
un-romantic, but of course,
that happens
in romcoms all the time.
People are trying to get back
with their original couples.
-Yeah, people.
You know, the rom part
is that the rom
isn't working out good for them.
-So then that becomes
an that provides the com.
-Yeah, the com part is, yeah,
it just comes naturally after.
-Do you like romcoms?
-I love romcoms, but it depends
on the altitude I'm at.
-Interesting.
-So if I'm in an airplane?
-Yeah.
-First of all, I watched
"The Intern" on an airplane
with --
-Anne Hathaway?
-The little known actor.
-Yeah.
-DeNiro?
-DeNiro that's his name.
DeNiro. Yeah, Italian guy. Good.
-He's going to break through.
-He's going to make it
this kid.
He's going to make it.
-He's good.
-I caught that on an airplane
and the whole time, I'm just
[imitates crying]
He just wants love in his life.
-I's think on an airplane.
-But.
-Ooh, look at those.
Why don't you tell us
that when you hosted "SNL"?
-I -- you guys
were going a mile a minute.
I'll just trying to hang on.
Thanks for having me.
I'm not going to bring any bits.
You know.
-I think I've cried
on an airplane
watching someone else's romcom
like one seat.
Like through the gap of seats
and you just because again,
sometimes to some degree,
a classic '90s romcom is almost
a silent movie. You know --
-I've always said that.
I've always said that.
-That's what we first
collected on.
-I say this if only
no one was talking.
And maybe someone was like
playing piano in my living room.
-But like fast piano a little
bit faster than you like it?
Yeah.
-Yeah. Julia Roberts.
So you know she needs love.
Everything. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Exactly.
-The natural transition.
-Just very natural.
-I pitched that for this movie,
but they turned it down.
-They turned it down?
-They said, "We want talking."
-Oh, well, I mean, the talking
in the clip was great,
so I think they might have been
right on that one.
-Yeah, I'm into the talkies.
-Yeah, yeah.
You think the talkies
are going to make it.
-I think the talkies, DeNiro,
you know, it's got us --
-The talkies are going to make
it, DeNiro's gonna make it,
aliens are showing up
eventually.
-Absolutely.
-Alright.
I have a lot more questions,
we'll be right back
with more from Charlie Day.